bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france est ce que cette
décision vous convient elle est
totalement satisfaisante puisqu'elle
correspond exactement à ce que nous
avons plaidé au nom des 21 requérant que
nous défendions ce matin devant le très
bien ministre hâtif alors justement que
demande exactement vos clients au haut
du collectif 21
alors vous savez que la préfète du
bas-rhin à des prix un premier arrêté
qui a été suspendu par le tribunal
adminstratif confirmée par le conseil
d'état et devait reprendre un deuxième
ce qu'elle a fait nous allons contester
ce deuxième arrêtées puisqu'en fait elle
a pris 13 arrêté différent pour les
treize plus grandes communes du bas rhin
ont respectant partiellement ce que le
conseil d'état lui demander pour les 13
communes les douze communes autre que
strasbourg mais on ne le respecte en pas
en ce qui concerne strasbourg à savoir
que le masque respecte reste est
obligatoire tout le temps 24 heures sur
24 dans les rues de strasbourg nous
contestions cela en disant qu'il fallait
définir des zones précises au sein de
strasbourg dans les quartiers dans
lesquels soit en fonction des horaires
ou de la densité de population ou de la
fréquentation ce port du masque était
véritablement indispensable à ces
moments là et c'est exactement ce que
dit le tribunal administratif dans sa
décision d'aujourd'hui dans cette
ordonnance de référé liberté qui a été
rendue ce matin puisqu'il impose jeu
reprend la formule exacte avant le 18
septembre à midi à la préfète de
reprendre un encore un nouvel arrêté
donc ce sera le deuxième essai
respectivement le troisième essai en
indice firent en identifiant dans les
quartiers strasbourgeois qui ne sont pas
caractérisés par une grande densité ou
une forte fréquentation les zones
précises dans lesquelles le port du
masque serait indispensable au protéger
la santé c'est la formule de la qui est
employé par le tribunal
donc vous pensez que les suit en fait
vont aller dans le sens de vos clients
du collectif 21 qui réclament donc de
fixer des périmètres précis dans les
communes concernées
c'est ce que nous demandions nous avons
fait valoir des arguments de bon sens
qui avait été repris par le conseil
d'état en disant qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire de porter le masque
chirurgical à certains endroits de
strasbourg à des heures tardives de la
soirée ou de la nuit ou matinale par
exemple nous avons sur le ban de la
commune de strasbourg des forêts
domaniales
qui sont absolument pas fréquenter
évidemment en semaine ou à des horaires
de bureau et où les gens peuvent
facilement respecter la distanciation
sociale sans être contraint de porter un
masque il en va de même de la plupart
des parcs urbains de strasbourg vous
avez peut-être entendu tout début de ce
journal les annonces faites justement ce
qui concerne les bouches-du-rhône où là
il ya des mesures sanitaires qui sont
renforcés puisque il ya 27 villes où le
port du masque sera obligatoire comment
vous réagissez d'ailleurs à ces annonces
alors chaque situation doit être
individualisée c'est justement ce qui
est demandé au préfet c'est pour ça que
les préfets sont compétents sur une zone
précise géographique c'est le cas pour
le préfet du bas rhin qui est compétent
pour le bas rhin et qui doit donc
adapter les mesures de distanciation ou
de port du masque à la situation telle
qu'elle existe dans notre département la
situation des bouches du rhône est
différente de celle du parent mais vous
à l'évolution justement de du virus
aujourd'hui il se rendant dans tout
l'hexagone est ce que vous ne craignez
pas qu'aux finalement votre victoire
elle soit de courte durée
le préfet doit prendre ses
responsabilités à un moment donné mais
il doit aussi respecter les libertés
publiques c'est ce que nous avons
toujours plaidé
il faut comprendre que mes clients les
21 requérant que je défende et ne sont
pas contre le port du masque ça a
toujours été dit ils sont pour le port
du masque mais pour le port du masque
intelligente c'est à dire quand il sert
à quelque chose
il est avéré désormais la plupart des
spécialistes honnête le dise que le port
du masque à l'extérieur sur la voie
publique hors cas de rassemblements
publics ça c'est un cas différent mais
si vous êtes simplement sur la chaussée
enfin sur un trottoir et que vous
croisez quelqu'un le port du masque ne
sert à rien et c'est ce qu'avait dit
d'ailleurs le premier ministre edouard
philippe dans une déclaration qu'il
avait faite dans une interview sur tf1
le 15 mars dans le journal de 13h en
disant que le port du masque dans la
population générale et dans la rue ne
servait à rien et c'est la vérité
selon vous pour conclure est-ce qu'il
faut une réponse juridique justement à
la responsabilité individuelle de porter
le mas dans ce contexte de regain des
décontaminations ocvidh 19 mai la
répression ne sert à rien toutes ces
mesures préfectorales sont assorties
d'amendés voire même de peines de prison
en cas de récidive mais tout cela ne
sert à rien il faut faire confiance à
l'intelligence collective de chacun
d'entre nous
qui peut facilement déterminer si dans
une zone précise il n'est pas en mesure
de respecter la distanciation physique
par rapport à son prochain et à ce
moment-là il porte le masque je crois
que nos citoyens sont suffisamment
adulte pour déterminer ces cas de figure
et le préfet doit simplement poser un
cadre général
merci à vous marque jean tolbiac
rappelle que vous êtes avocat au barreau
de strasbourg de strasbourg merci
d'avoir un géant direction arte france